- So what about like you interviewing me
what would you ask me if you
were going to interview me?
- Well first I saw your
audition for American Idol.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So I would one,
love to know why you
decided to sing 'At Last.'
I would also love to know,
because I know that you made
your own clothing for it.
- I did.
- Yes, so I would love
to know if you would ever
consider becoming a fashion designer.
(Kelly laughing)
And if so--
- I love it.
- What type of clothes would you make?
And what would the name
of your clothing line be?
- Okay.
I got you.
I sang 'At Last' because,
well one I had no idea it was a TV show.
I was just,
they asked me to sing a song.
I had no idea why I was there,
but I was pretty certain
it paid some money,
and I was like,
"Cool, what do you want me to sing?"
And so I was about to sing at a wedding
and I was singing 'At
Last' at the wedding.
So I just sang that 'cause I
was about to sing it somewhere.
I made my own clothes not
because I'm super into fashion,
but because my place had just burned down.
- No.
- And all my belongings
but pictures were gone.
So those were actually jeans that I cut
and put safety pins in them
and made a shirt 'cause I'm so cool.
If I ever had a fashion line,
it would definitely be
just jeans and t-shirts
because that's what I love.
(audience cheering)
I don't know what I'd call it.
- Something like 'Burned
Down' or something.
- Yeah, burned down.
- Fire, yeah.
- Yeah. Burned, oh Burned Out.
That's what we're gonna call our--
- Burned Out.
- Our clothing line.
Okay. We've got it now.
We've got it.
All right, well I have,
I have something to tell you.
I love matching young girls with women
who can guide them toward their dreams.
So I have someone here I want you to meet.
I know you're a big fan of hers.
So we've been keeping this
special secret all day long.
That's why you've been
trapped in a room, sorry.
Arianna will you come out?
(audience cheering)
(lighthearted guitar music)
This is Arianna Huffington.
Okay, be careful.
That's a tight spot.
We need to fix that.
All right, so what.
This is crazy.
We've been trying to hide
this from you all day.
You're like,
"Why would they lock me in a room
without a TV or anything.
No good snacks in here.
Like, what's happening."
But what advice would
you give to her, Arianna?
Being a journalist yourself?
- Well first of all, you're amazing.
You really are.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- You are, too.
- And it's so important to remember that,
because as you said about Kevin Hart.
Not everything goes perfectly in life.
- Yes.
- So remember whatever
happens you are amazing.
You keep believing in yourself.
And I want you to come
and intern for one day at Thrive Global.
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
- Yes, I would love that.
- So we'll bring you to New York.
You can interview anyone who works there
about anything you want.
Including maybe asking
them how much time they
spend on social media.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- You know.
Do they compare themselves
with Kate Upton?
- No.
- And Kelly.
- [Kelly] Don't do it.
- And then we will publish
it on Thrive Global.
- That sounds amazing.
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
- That's, it'll be your
biggest like publication.
That's amazing.
What do you feel?
How do you feel?
- Amazing!
(laughing)
- You're gonna be awesome.
And before you leave LA,
I actually have a surprise,
a special surprise for you
from our friends at Access Hollywood,
you're actually gonna spend a
day interning there as well.
You'll get to meet Mario Lopez
and see what it takes
to be a top notch
entertainment news reporter.
Does that sound good?
- Yes.
(audience cheering)